hey guys it's just seen and I'm so
excited to have you guys here in my
kitchen with me and today I'll back up a
little so not too close and in-your-face
because this is a 180 video it's also in
3d so if you have a headset go grab one
put it on I won't wait but you can
restart the video but this is gonna be
super fun because today I'm going to
make you pancakes the pancakes that
we're gonna make today are very special
because they're 3d pancakes have you
ever seen somebody make pancakes in 3d I
don't think you have but today you will
so we're gonna be using this this is
shaken pour so let me get my ingredients
ready which is just water it couldn't be
any easier I've put some water in here
and I dumped it on the pan first step we
have our Bisquick shake and pour now we
shake and we pour but first we have to
add some water so the first step is to
add one and a half cups of cold water to
container one and a half i need a
measuring cup oh look here's my phone so
this is a dry measuring cup but I
clearly doesn't really matter
cool water do you think I'm gonna spill
this oh shoot I did so how much water
did I spill
like that much I made such a mess all
right time to shake turn bottle upside
down tap lid shake container 30 seconds
something at the camera you know what's
crazy about a 180 video as normally I
could hide all of the things that are
found here but over here this is all
this stuff that you normally wouldn't
see cuz this is where I actually usually
have my camera oh god that was an
accident
oh let's get this thing all turned on
and ready for bacon grilling 30 seconds
I think I've probably cook this for
about 30 minutes at this point but now I
need to get something to spray the pan
this thing's bulging look at that you
don't really see this in 3d I know you
guys are super close right now but I
wanted you to really feel like you're
you're a pancake who's a pancake me and
you ready for the spray I'm spraying a
lot just because I'm gonna make sure
this is real greased up god I want to
spring you guys so bad but that's not a
good idea
alright oh my god absolutely I did not
mean to do that
oh my god you guys are gonna think that
I planned this for the video but I said
no I will not make a mess because I
don't want to clean it up okay well
there's still enough in here to make a
pancake so just just leave that there
for the time being I cannot believe it
oh my gosh here we go
wonder if this is hot enough how big of
a pancake should I make it Mady mommy
made a mess
Mady come here oh that's oh he's going
to listen be a square
all right guess I'll put another one
here
who needs half the batter on the floor
these are getting crispy I think my
goodness need a spatula oh my phone
bigger spatula oh yeah look at that nice
nice nice nice nice okay a spatula time
I are they ready they're bubbling okay
so you guys I like to flip spatulas a
lot I can't believe okay I'm just gonna
flip the friggin pancake because at this
point I'm gonna completely destroy my
kitchen that's a perfect pancake have
you guys never seen anything more
perfect oh my goodness these are so
perfect look at this color the
consistency may be the secret is you
have to spill half of it on the floor
I should probably get some plates ready
oh we also have to heat up some syrup
syrup sir syrup maple syrup gosh this is
probably expired I haven't used syrup in
14 years
looks Canadian to me let's heat this up
a little like 15 seconds let's do
another flip here oh okay
okay that's not ready yet maybe any just
turn up the heat a little no I don't I
should just leave this be maple syrup
how do I know when they're done you look
what I did I made a pancake mess what
did I do
I know it's pretty disappointing well
let's check out these pancakes and see
how they're cooking up it's looking
pretty good I think these are almost
ready well I think this is backwards I
probably should have this facing me okay
I think this one's ready to be plated
plate number two yeah and oh cool
time to eat I need to get myself a chair
so I can sit down and really enjoy these
[Music]
I need a fork you know what I also need
in case I want to cut them up oops
forgot before
well let's be real I guess I really
don't even need a fork let's just dunk
this look at that maple syrup goodness
oh my gosh why do I'm not open a brunch
restaurant immediately go eat up I'm
gonna go eat this in the privacy of my
own off